Hey Thoughty2 here.
I have a question for you, when was the last
time you watched the news and didn't see bad
news.
When did you least read a headline that read
"Sorry folks, no news today because all is
fine and dandy in the world".
Apart from that one day, on 18th April 1930
when there was no news, so they simply played
piano music for 15 minutes instead of the
usual news bulletin.
Yes that actually happened.
It's easy to believe that we're all doomed.
With the Gaza Strip, ISIS, Ebola, countless
civil wars, school shootings, killer cops
and a handful of highly questionable world
leaders.
It seems that every year the world is falling
deeper and deeper into a pit of hatred, deceit,
murder, war, terrorism and despair.
One could easily believe that the world is
more dangerous than it has ever been and only
getting more so.
But what's the truth?
Are things getting better or worse?
What does the outlook look like for the future
of mankind?
To find out we need to do one very important
thing, completely ignore every news source
in the world.
You see, there is an intrinsic problem with
news, they only report the bad news and the
worse the news is the higher billing it receives.
Front page headlines are reserved for only
the most miserable events that unfold around
the world each day.
Whether it be TV news, tabloids or even social
media, news outlets need to attract large
numbers of viewers or they will inevitably
fail.
So naturally the most compelling stories are
chosen to make headlines.
Well, it makes sense doesn't it?
By its very definition news would not be news
if it was not something out of the ordinary.
Although it's nice to hear, reporting that
millions of cars arrived safely at their destinations
this week is not news, but reporting a fatal
collision is.
And because news only reports the bad events
it gives the majority of people the impression
that these awful events are far more likely
to occur than they actually do.
Headlines would have us believe that terrorists
are waiting for us, planning their next attack
around every corner, at every airport or transportation
system.
A data scientist recently calculated the odds
of a person dying in a terrorist attack.
He concluded that your chances are 1 in 25
million.
Let me put that into perspective, your chance
of dying in the bathtub is 1 in 680,000, so
you're 36 times more likely to die in the
tub than at the hands of a terrorist.
Also, you're 2.5 times more likely to become
a president and 2 times more likely to become
an astronaut, than to die in a terrorist attack.
Of course this is no solace to the unfortunate
victims of such attacks but it just goes to
demonstrate how news headlines can artificially
inflate our worries and negative expectations
of the World.
But the reality is really rather different.
What if, despite everything you've heard and
everything you've read, I told you, that the
world is more peaceful right now than ever
before.
Many experts, including German economist Max
Roser have said that we are currently living
in the most peaceful period of our species'
existence.
Max Roser of Oxford University runs the website
Our World in Data and this astonishing chart
shows the global deaths in conflicts per 100,000
people, every year since 1400.
The past 15 years have seen a rapid and substantial
drop in conflict deaths worldwide.
But that's just in war, what about on our
streets, what about theft, murder and rape?
Well, this graph shows the homicide rates
per 100,000 people in various European regions
between the year 1300 and today, that's quite
a decline.
But that goes all the way back to the middle
ages when your best friend would bash your
head in for a leg of lamb.
How about over the past couple of decades?
This graph shows the rates of robbery, homicide
and vehicle theft across the G7 countries
between 1995 and 2010, all three crimes have
reduced significantly.
But hold on, what about terrorism?
Surely that's becoming more prevalent each
year, not a month goes by when we don't hear
about an awful attack somewhere around the
World.
Yes, it's true that jihadist terrorism has
increased over the past two decades.
But overall, if we take every event of terrorism
from the past 50 years, the frequency of attacks
has dropped significantly, especially over
the past decade, according Our World in Data
in 2006 there were 6,660 counts of terrorism
worldwide, by 2009 that had dropped to just
560.
And the number of deaths from terrorism has
dropped also.
When we take all these factors and put them
together it creates an interesting picture
as to what is happening with World peace and
that's exactly what the institute for economics
and peace has done.
Every year the Sydney-based research firm
analyses thousands of bits of data from every
country and produces a peace score and a ranking
for every country on Earth, called the Global
Peace Index.
In their latest, 2017 index the five most
peaceful countries on Earth are Iceland, New
Zealand, Portugal, Austria and Denmark.
And the least peaceful are Syria, Afghanistan,
Iraq, South Sudan and Yemen.
But if you look at the change in each country's
peace index over the past 10 years something
strange has happened which explains why overall
the world is becoming less violent whilst
the newspapers are doing the opposite and
only filling up with more violence.
The peace gap is widening.
The authors of the Global Peace Index have
stated that over the past ten years 81 countries
that were already peaceful, have only become
more peaceful, yet 79 countries that were
already un-peaceful have become even less
peaceful.
According to the Global Peace Index Europe
is the most peaceful region in the World,
and every year since the index began, European
countries have only got more and more peaceful
each year, except for France which has seen
a slight drop in its rankings due to the recent
terrorist attacks in the country.
However, the publishers of the study have
said that today most European countries are
now more peaceful than they have ever been
in recorded history.
Conversely, the world's least peaceful regions,
the Middle East and North Africa, have only
got less peaceful each and every year and
are now less peaceful than ever.
But as always, there is one developed country
that has bucked the trend of increased peace
amongst its peers.
Not only has the United States of America
dropped its ranking every year but its peace
index has also fallen faster than any other
major developed country.
In 2015 the US was ranked 94 out of 163 countries,
in 2016 it was ranked 103 and this year it
fell again to 114 out of 163 countries, a
rapid drop which the researchers attribute
in part to increased political instability
and divide in recent years.
But how did Iceland get to be number one on
the list?
Not only that, Iceland has always been number
one, for as long as the Global Peace Index
has existed, Iceland has been ranked the most
peaceful country on Earth.
And the reason behind it is fascinating.
Iceland isn't the world's most peaceful place
because of the country's remoteness and its
beautiful scenery, although it certainly helps.
Iceland is so peaceful because it has to be.
Iceland is one of the harshest environments
on the planet and for hundreds of years the
natives have had to take unusual steps to
survive the bitterly cold, unforgiving tundra.
If they spent all their time fighting one
another they would have perished to the elements,
so instead they had to work together to survive
mother nature.
Throughout the ages it has been perfectly
acceptable and quite common in Icelandic culture
to enter someone's house, even if you have
never met them and even if they're not home,
and make yourself a cup of tea in their kitchen,
to warm yourself up.
That's a level of trust and community that
would be completely unfathomable for citizens
of most other countries.
But it was born out of necessity from living
in such a cold, inhospitable country.
And although the terrain is inhospitable,
the people are not and their respect and trust
of one-another is what makes Iceland the most
peaceful country in the world.
The average homicides per year in the US is
15,000, the average homicides per year in
Iceland is one, just one and that truly is
something to be proud of.
Thanks for watching.